wir kommen zur frage motto ich glaube
ich muss nichts mehr erklären nichts
erklären ich mache hervor
ich habe gespannt hier ja die hoffnung
genau texte und videos die viele
emotional packen woher hast du das
talenten geschichten menschen zu
berühren
eine gute frage woher ich dieses talent
hat ich finde erst mal cool dass
überhaupt jemand das so auffällt dass
den leuten auffällt dass ich sehr gerne
geschichten erzähle die so patches sind
also die leute berühren weiß nicht
vielleicht gute geschichten erzähler und
ab das talent dazu dass ich das noch auf
rap ebene verpacken kann ich freue mich
darüber und wo er das talent genau kommt
weiß ich nicht ich habe keine musik so
direkt eine familie von dem ich wusste
oder so ist einfach wie es ist in die
wiege gelegt stoppt wenn man messi frage
warum er so guter fußballer ist bitte
das gleiche sagen sie man sollte sich
auch ein bisschen in bescheidenheit üben
der schule gut in deutschland
durchschnittlich schönheit muss ich
ehrlich sein ich will jetzt nicht so
hervorheben oder so ganz normaler
stürmer der eigentlich immer gelangweilt
was vom unterricht und danach der sich
ausgetobt aber dann hast du angefangen
texte zu schreiben
18 mit 18 und dann dann direkt an
angriff sturm
apropos berta rein euro mutig sein könnt
ihr auch dazu jetzt verlässlich jetzt
zusätzlich mal gucken wie hässlich und
vor allem für wen so hässlich wie kate
moss am morgen
ich habe keine ahnung gesang simple und
ein feature mit einer internationalen
größe geht ihr das geld aus oder wieso
versucht mit allen mitteln zu werden
ich versuche mehr hinzu wenn man das
geld ausgeht also ich war mutter meinte
man muss sich am abend zu machen dass
man einen die frage die gestellt ist die
so beschreibt gestellt worden dass ich
dir sagen müsste mein freund ich glaube
dir deine deutschkenntnisse langsam aus
nein ich meine einfach die frage ist so
bescheuert gestellt also dass ich ich
bin mein geld wert ist arbeit haben oder
du steckst du dein letztes geld noch ein
um mit mühe und not noch einen erfolg
ich hab doch erstmal wir für kein
feature geld ich dachte das motto also
ich weiß wird kay fischer barrel und
zweitens samples was ich verstehe diese
frei
fest steht sie absichtlich nicht kommt
noch eine rote karte sah ich verstehe
diese freilich will action haben aber
die feinde so dumm gestellt so das kann
ja gar nicht sein name ganz hoch
intelligent dass du selber mit solisten
die wiese lagen formulieren immer mehr
tiefgründige und gefühlvolles sonst bist
du auch weich geworden wie viele andere
web beim alter ja ich bin reich geworden
das hat folgenden grund ich habe die
rente beantragt und ich möchte
dementsprechend natürlich auch die rente
kassieren
und ich möchte ihn früh jahren in rente
gehen deswegen werde ich jetzt zwei
spiele mit live band auf tour gehen
meiner freundin eine glatze rasieren
damit das sehr erwachsen alles wirkt
wird mir ein polohemd passender zu
kaufen wie du dir eins hast damit ich
auch gestanden aussehe
nichtsdestotrotz bin ich nicht weich
geworden ich finde es noch immer noch
bock und ist immer noch sehr viel hartes
zeug dabei aber dir zuliebe werde ich
versuchen bzw
der freie zudem werde ich versuchen in
zukunft mehr genauigkeit gezogen damit
alle glücklich sind und alles hat ist
kaum noch eine rolle
scheiß auf die grünen fragen erziehung
brauchen wir nur noch diese ekligen
freien und ok das zeugt von charakter
dass ihr habt alle charakter mit diesen
fragen so kommt schon wieder ein
lateinischer titel machst du einen auf
gebildet
also ehrlich gesagt nein ich mache nicht
auf gebildet ich bin der lateinischen
sprache nicht mächtig wenn ich ehrlich
bin so ich bin einfach nur gewisse
wollte cool und ich habe es versucht so
zu verpacken
es tut mir leid wenn ich irgend einer
mit zu nahe getreten bin ich werde in
zukunft versuchen nur noch deutschen
zunehmend kreiere glücklich ist aber ich
kann es nicht jedem recht machen
geäußert einfach nur das kann man
natürlich nicht aber ich versuche und zu
komponieren recht zu machen dann werde
ich im winter und sagen wo wir sie alle
glücklich aber wie kommst du wie
grimassen lateinischen text sagst du ich
will das klinikum frieden denn bereits
ab lateinisches ich gehe ich beschäftige
mich ist jetzt nicht so dass ich jetzt
die sprache aber ich beschäftige mich
okay ich nicht nur wenn ich all mache
beschäftige ich mich mit der sprache ich
finde sie einfach cool ist eine sprache
die ausgestorben ist
man muss sie am leben halten okay was
für ihre bildung anstatt danke zu sagen
super man muss auf jeden fall mal sein
hirn anstrengen um rauszufinden das
album eine rote meer von diesem klingt
director ist werden mehr rote machen
müssen ehrlich nur noch rot inzucht
diesem welt einfach nur noch folgen euro
tragen
20 roten 20 rote welche willst du denn
sie hat er sich dann die man traurig
dass es keine magazin selber recht
ausgereift einem mitreißen zu einem
mitreißenden geschichten über deine ist
ein schreibfehler ist jetzt die frage so
vor wie sie gesteht zum einen
mitreißende geschichten über deine
mutter um beziehung zum anderen frauen
verachtende terrors verlässt damit ich
deine glaubwürdigkeit
zum einen mitreißenden geschichten über
deine kindheit deine mutter und
beziehung zum anderen frauen verachtende
terror war sehr komisch gestellt worden
aber ja das ist ein bisschen das ist
komisch formuliert ist
das klingt schon sehr nach lieutenant
direktor suchen das ist ja auch
intelligente retten
ich bin lese ich auch global gebilde
hier seid jährige laura also verlierst
du damit nicht seine glaubwürdigkeit
ich glaube nicht das interessiert mich
gar nicht ob irgendjemand glaubt dass
ich meine glaubwürdigkeit verliere so
lange ich in den spiegel schauen kann
und den typen dort antreffen wenn ich
cool findet bzw das macht von dem ich
glaube dass es richtig ist verlegt ich
meine glaubwürdigkeit ich meine es ist
auch nicht frauenverachtend ich meine
musik ist niemals verfrachten
wie gesagt wir haben schon über das
humor dinge geredet sollte man das ganze
mag vielleicht ein bisschen entspannt
angehen lassen ich meine ich war nie der
rapper irgendwie gesagt hat alle frauen
sind scheiße alle von sind minuten und
ich war wochen die der report hat alle
frauen sind tollen man muss jede frau
respektieren es kommt jetzt ist du hast
auch manchmal schlechte tage eine frau
hat auch manchmal ihre tage sogar öfter
als männer
wahrscheinlich aber nichtsdestotrotz
frauen haben auch gewisse phasen wo sie
sagen scheiß auf alle männer so weiß
warum
es ist einfach so wenn die einfach
genervt sind von ihren typen oder so
sagen ja auch ach scheiß auf alle männer
so aber wisst ihr mit humor und so muss
man das ganze aufsehen wenn wir typen
auch mal die schnauze voll von frauen
dürfen wir auch genau zu sagen scheiß
auf frauen wir machen jetzt ein eigenes
ding wir gehen raus und können dann die
bars so muss man es auch ein bisschen
sehen so weit und es wäre sollte man
nicht so drauf rumreiten er das gesagte
darf nie wieder das sagen wir sind neben
einer demokratie jeder sagen was er will
und so unglaublich trotzdem was als
einen fall habe ich du hast einfach wenn
ich morgens in den spiegel sehen in die
aesculap sich einen ganz netten
charismatischen jungen typen der
eigentlich weltoffen ist und zu jedem
korrekt ist ihm auch gut gegenübertritt
denn sehe ich eigentlich so weist aber
manchmal wache ich morgens auf und denkt
scheiße alter was für eine hässliche
fratze erste mal lieber im bett
geblieben wer von beiden ist hart weil
ok stopp des gerade ein tor gefallen ich
habe auch während der partie dortmund
gegen bayern münchen ein video nach dem
anderen nun ein feature mit batman bist
du wieder heiß ich war nie kalt wie ok
letzte die letzte last but not least
waren die comstor willkommen
super danach hat mich der fragekatalog
nein sonst über sehr persönliche dinge
woher nimmst du das selbstbewusst damit
privaten thema an die öffentlichkeit zu
gehen so gute frage ich habe mir ehrlich
gesagt nie so darüber gedanken gemacht
ob das jetzt oder selbstbewusstsein zu
göttig ich finde gerade bisschen
bemerkenswert dass es für andere leute
wahrscheinlich dafür andere leute da
selbstbewusst jetzt zu geld für mich ist
dass ich habe es als normal angesehen
dass man mit rapmusik auch dinge machen
muss beziehungsweise machen kann
womit man sich vielleicht doch
angreifbar macht weil wir die frage
schon so laut dass man private dinge
auspackt aber ich versuche so zu
verpacken dass die leute sich damit
identifizieren können beziehungsweise
nachvollziehen können so ist immer noch
sehr real und nah am menschen drin
vielen dank alles gleich dank dir danke
werden